last night tuatanga by Loa was  structured off the field with head and  neck injuries and a lot of people are  mad that he was on the field in the  first place last Sunday against the  bills tuo went down and hit his head  hard he showed clear signs of gross  motor instability he shook his head  while he was on the ground stood up and  then stumbled but the dolphin said he  cleared concussion protocol last night  again he hit his head hard thankfully he  was conscious with movement in all of  his extremities he is set to get an MRI  when they get back to Miami he has been  diagnosed with concussion Dolphins head  coach Mike McDaniels said that the  Dolphins don't mess with concussions he  said quote if there's any inclination  that someone has a concussion they go  into concussion protocol the NFL PA has  now opened an investigation into how the  Dolphins handled to his injury on Sunday  and if he truly should have been on the  field last night